Speaker 1: le to say that the dam is breaking
when it comes to Republicans and gun safety
regulations. In fact, it's not breaking in
total. But we are starting to see some cracks as
multiple Republicans, including an NRA endorsed
Republican, are now doing a 180 and saying it's
time for a gun safety regulation. Something has
to be done. I have two examples of that for you.
We're first going to look at an interview
that Republican Congressman Adam Kinzinger did
on CNN. Now, caveats, Adam Kinzinger is leaving
Congress. Okay. Adam Kinzinger is not a Trump
Republican. He is an anti-Trump Republican.
And so some people will write him off and say
he's not really a Republican because of that.
But this is a Republican who for a long time
opposed banning assault style rifles. And
now he said it's something he's open to.
This is a major change. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Congressman, you do still oppose
a ban on the kind of assault weapons that
were used in the shooting. Can you explain
why private citizens need weapons of war?
Speaker 3: Look, I have opposed a ban, you know,
fairly recently. I think I'm open to a ban
now. Well, it's going to depend on what it
looks like because there's a lot
of nuances on what constitutes,
you know, certain things. But I'm getting to
the point where I have to wonder, maybe it's
maybe somebody to own one. Maybe you need an extra
license, maybe you need extra training. And so the
question is, is it a ban versus an additional
certification? But yeah, I got to tell you,
I mean, 99.9% of people that don't air, as we
all know, are not going to walk into a school
and do this. But the problem is, for those
that support the Second Amendment, like me,
we have to be coming to the table with ways
to mitigate 18 year olds buying these guns
and walking into schools. My side's not doing
that right. My side's not coming forward with
reasonable ways to defend an amendment that we
think is very important there. And so I'm looking
at this going fine if people are going to put
forward solutions about certifying maybe who can
buy an assault weapon. I'm certainly open to that.
Speaker 1: So listen, it's no big gun
safety declaration. He's leaving Congress. He's
saying maybe it's just more restrictions and not
really banning them, but it's a change and it's an
important change. Now, the reality is that a ban
alone isn't enough to really interrupt the
school shooting fiasco we have in this country.
But it's maybe one part and I talked about that
in my list of ten specific gun safety proposals
that I outlined last week. It's also important to
mention Kinzinger still voted with Trump 90% of
the time while Trump was president. So but listen,
he's willing here. Okay. And so let's let's praise
it for what it is and not go overboard. Now,
here's another example then. Chris Jacobs,
who's a straight up NHRA, endorsed congressman
from New York after the Buffalo shooting.
He also says that his perspective has changed.
There's a great piece in The Buffalo News
which says Congressman Chris Jacobs of Orchard
Park made a surprising about face on gun control
issues, becoming perhaps the first congressional
Republican to call for an assault weapons ban
in the wake of the recent mass shootings
in Buffalo and Duvall de Texas. At a news
conference and later with the Buffalo News,
Jacobs, who was endorsed by the NRA in 2020,
laid out a series of new stances that run contrary
to the Republican Party line on guns. In addition
to saying he would vote for a Democratic bill
banning assault weapons, he also said he would
back raising the age on some gun purchases to
21. My suggestion was 25, but 2021 is something
limiting the capacity of magazines. I agree. And
banning the sale of military style body armor to
civilians. In the interview, Jacobs said the
two recent shootings forced him to reevaluate
his position on guns and to research
where he wanted to stand in the future.
So what can we say? I can't say the dam is
breaking. The NRA's incredibly strong, but there
are cracks starting to form. And it really remains
to be seen whether this will become anything and
whether anything will happen or not. This could
start to achieve change or at least start putting
pressure on people to make a change. And it's
very interesting. Adam Kinzinger, Chris Jacobs,
let's see who else had themselves to the list.
The claim in Washington is that this is different.
Now we've heard that a thousand times
before because we've had a thousand or
more mass shootings, but it remains to
be seen whether that will be the case